Question about circulated tumor cells. I've been told they continue to be in your body for the duration of your life. It's just a matter of monetary.
Are they inactive cells? Active cells stem cells? I know that RGCC looks at them, but do cancer marker tests also track them?
Cancer marker tests do not track circulated tumor cells. Cancer markers themselves are different enzymes that are given off by a lot of different cells.
Not just cancer cells, so that's why there's a normal range of tumor markers.
So the normal range of a CA-153 is 0 to 35, meaning you could not have cancer and you could have a CA-153 of 15.
Well, why would that be? Because they're not specific to cancer. Other cells give those off too.
Circulated tumor cells are cancer stem cells, so they're not yet in a rapid replication phase.
It is disputable that you have circulated tumor cells the rest of your life.
I would argue that the chance of a person who had a diagnosis of cancer, having circulated tumor cells that are still alive but not maybe not in rapid replication, somewhere in the body is quite possible and highly probable.
It should be always doing things to keep your cancer at bay. I've heard too many stories of trying to throw along my 25 years of helping people with cancer and people thinking that they've cured their disease that they stop using the right for they stop doing all the stuff that got them to the point of, you know, good spot with their cancer and then the cancer quote unquote comes back with the vengeance.
Well, it's because it never was totally gone. There was circulated tumor cells. That's why I disagree and you've heard we say this a hundred times with an oncologist saying you have no evidence of disease.
Well, that's actually a better terminology, which is a new term versus, you know, saying that you're cured.
You don't have cancer anymore or something like that. You should always say that you're in remission. You're doing well, keep doing what you're doing to keep yourself there. That's my point of view.